I have a story for you today from Altona New
York where the town court justice named Kyle
canning has been permanently barred from the
bench because he posted a pro Trump Manga
Facebook post with a new sonnet.
Pretty Nice stuff, right?
I mean, not hugely surprising, but uh, at
least there are some consequences here.
So this guy posted a picture of a noose with
the text that red, if we want to make America
great again, we will have to make evil people
fear punishment against again.
Um, this is a judge who's posting this to
social media and canning had already resigned
back in June when this first went public and
then now he's been permanently banned and
has to agree never to seek or accept judicial
office at any time in the future.
Now, why am I bringing this particular story
up?
It has nothing to do with this judge individually.
It's great that this guy was caught, a complaint
was filed, he's been barred from the bench
and he personally won't be making judicial
decisions in the future and that's a good
thing.
But there's a much bigger issue here and it's
an issue I've been talking more and more about
over the last three to six months, which is
that in general, the number of judges that
Donald Trump has appointed who now are serving
at different levels of courts.
This particular one is not a Trump appointed
judge.
To be clear, the real issue is that increasingly
thanks to Donald Trump, the courts are filled
with people like this guy.
Most of them have the wherewithal and common
sense not to post this stuff to Facebook,
but they're thinking the same things.
They're making judicial decisions on the basis
of these beliefs that they hold.
And by the way, they're more and more under
the radar, uh, um, and they are destroying
the fabric of the American judiciary as we
know it.
So there, there are actually really serious
problems in general with right-wing judges.
Remember that we know right-wing brains and
left wing brains are different.
There.
There are neurological differences, brain
differences between left wingers and right-wingers.
We've talked about the really good studies
into how the fear centers of brains are way
bigger.
If you are, if you have two judges, one who
is much more afraid because of what their
brain makeup is, you are going to see drastically
different or at least different.
We would presume decisions made about punishments
and other legal decisions, judicial decisions
that they make, right wingers are more likely
to see others as inherently bad or as inherently
sinners.
It, depending on their religious persuasion.
That is definitely going to make you, if you
are a judge, choose very different punishments,
have a very different outlook about what it
is that should be done with the people that
are convicted.
For example, in the court that you preside
over and there's lots of really good research
about this stuff.
So what we have to understand is when we talk
about Trump destroying alliances, when we
talk about Trump tweeting that now the military
is going to kick out trans people or whatever
the case may be, we follow those stories.
We pay attention to them.
When Trump leaves, a lot of that stuff can
be reversed.
The next president, hopefully if it's the
right person, we'll be able to rebuild these
ruined alliances with other countries.
The next president will be able to, by executive
order, have reversed a lot of the things that
Donald Trump did by executive order.
Great.
The bigger issue is that Supreme Court justices
and other judges, a lot of these are lifetime
appointments and these are people who even
after Donald Trump is long gone from the White
House, are going to continue making an impact
on the fabric of the country on one of the
most important institutions that determines
that puts into effect one of the primary philosophical
things that distinguishes one country from
another, which is the sort of attitude and
philosophy of the Jewish judiciary and how
we punish people, rehabilitation versus punny,
all of this stuff.
This is an effect that Donald Trump is going
to have for a very long time, and so what
I go back to is the frustration and I have
no misconception.
It's mostly right-wingers responsible for
Donald Trump being president.
They're the ones that voted for him, but those
leftists, because I'm on the left, I want
to make sure that I'm cleaning up my house
as well.
The leftist who insisted Trump Hillary, they're
basically both establishment shills.
They're both just rich people.
It doesn't really matter which one becomes
president.
Obviously that didn't make sense from day
one, but one of the most acute and prevalent
areas where it makes such a difference is
when it comes to the judiciary and the judges
that are president and gets to select Donald
Trump by one measure now has a selected about
a quarter of the judges at a couple of different
levels.
Federal, I don't remember if it's federal
and appeals, federal and superior or whatever
the case may be.
So we've got the research.
These right wing judges are uh, biologically
different.
Their brains are different, their fear centers
are enlarged.
Uh, and then you've got a lot of them that
are thinking the same things.
Is this Kyle Canon guy who would love to or
at least agree with news pictures talking
about Magda?
They're not posting it.
This is one guy that we got out.
That's good news.
But the problem is really, really big.
And, and truly this is a bigger problem than
Trump.
Uh, in the short term, the best thing we can
do is get Trump out so that he stops being
able to appoint any judges whatsoever.
A reminder that the Kyle canning was not appointed
by Trump.
I understand that.
Uh, but bigger picture, we really have to
be thinking about the problems inherent with
the judiciary system that we have.